last night's episode of survivor 42 may
not have been as chaotic as last week's
but that didn't mean we weren't treated
to drama at tribal council yeah but
before we get into that over here we
have to talk about taco tribe member
jonathan young who just might cement
himself in the survivor hall of fame as
the most capable challenge
what as a what did i say beast challenge
beast thank you my director it's been a
it's the hairspray in my eye take a look
it's fine it's good tori can you learn
anything when you see a tribe lose early
and now they're dominating we all see
goliath like he's huge he's dominating
that last challenge that we could not
complete you even gave him credit you
said that was one of the most impressive
individual feats you have seen so
it's hard to not view them as like
indestructible because they have this
goliath and they seem to be working so
well but there's something that we have
to figure out that they're doing that
we're not doing yet survivors ready
[Music]
jonathan is ripping through the water
keep it going
he is doing it himself marianne is just
hanging on for the ride
taku gonna get there first you're good
taku
and now we're joined with our special
survivor correspondent and season 41
winner erica kasupanin hey erica hi
cheryl hi carlos it feels so good to be
back even on my little exile island
and i'm ready to break down everything
that went on during last night's
survivor okay well we obviously have to
first talk about the actual aquaman
i mean jonathan not only did he lead his
tribe to victory during the reward
challenge but he literally pulled his
team ahead for them to secure immunity
but i want to know erica do you think
jonathan's goliath status will work
against him i mean the audience has seen
that jonathan is a physical force and i
think on survivor standing out can be
good and standing out can be bad i think
the other problem that jonathan has is
that he is likable we see him being
really supportive to his tribe really
sweet to his tribe so i think that if
you are physically strong and you're
likeable
you could be a big threat down the line
all right but ahead of ika's
tribal council swathi got caught playing
both sides after telling tori drea and
romeo that she was their number one ally
in the game so do you think that was her
downfall
i just want to say bless swathi because
she played the game at 19 years old that
is a feat and she showed a lot of
maturity i mean she showed that she
understood where she stood on the tribe
she was able to correctly read the
situation and play the shot in the dark
but i think that she just wasn't able to
execute her plans really well and i
actually spoke with swathi not too long
ago about her thought process behind her
gameplay
we saw this amazing montage last night
of you telling drea romeo and tori that
you were their number one and as i'm
watching it every time a new one came up
i'm like oh no swappy what's happening
so can you share some more insight into
that strategy and who was actually your
number one
yeah i would say that um my number one
was probably rox and then probably tori
it was it wasn't um drea or romeo which
i think of learning that i'd said this
tutorial was probably the big thing that
set romeo andrea off was was realizing
that i actually really really did want
to work with her um but i would also say
in my defense romeo had been telling me
i was his number one from like day one
which is the only reason i said it to
him and i think draya had said it to me
also just like two seconds before that
clip that was aired so um it wasn't it
wasn't a thing that only i was doing
because like i was in either romeo or
dre is number one it was sort of
something that everybody honor tribe was
doing but i think
the big things are like one realizing
that i said it to tori
um and then two i think people just
didn't think that i was playing the game
as hard as everybody else so i think
realizing all at once like oh that i've
been doing all this stuff just made me
look very suspicious like i i think like
people bought the innocent thing a
little bit a little bit too much
i think that it is very common on
survivor to tell a lot of people that
they're your number ones but i think
that swathi identified it the problem is
you can tell people that you're their
number one but if people think that
you're messy they kind of don't really
care but if you can tell someone that
you're their number one and it's
believable and then it turns out you're
duplicitous that's when people really
feel betrayed and i think that that's
where her game went
well erica you're our number one 100
you're number one you're our one and
only yep for sure yeah one out here on
this island love your island love that